what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into infinity
wars part
four and uh again this is kind of
interesting this is uh
issue number four is a little strange
it's more of like
plot building but it's kind of crazy
because in truth it feels a little bit
rushed what jerry dugan does here is he
actually kind of
takes a couple concepts from house of m
a lot of people know what house of am is
right it's a story where scarlet witch
warps reality and then creates a new one
and then where really she eliminates the
current reality then creates a new one
where like everybody's most subconscious
dreams come true
essentially but in this one gamora with
the infinity stones had basically merged
all these heroes together so quote
unquote cut the universe's population in
half by like merging people together and
then threw them all in seoul world and
then created like a whole universe
within soul world and so it's kind of
interesting because
initially dugan didn't really seem to
explain that
traditionally seoul world is like its
own world right it has like rivers and
streams and mountains and so on and so
forth and it was always depicted a
certain way then marvel came back later
and basically turned soul world into the
marvel cinematic universe version of
soul world and so what kind of happened
here is it was like gamora had
sent all these characters into soul
world and then built a house in seoul
world and then put them all inside the
house so they don't really know
what soul world looks like they're not
really familiar with it instead they're
all just kind of residing in this
universe she threw in there now by
merging them all together marvel gave us
infinity warps at the end of the day it
wasn't really meant to be taken
seriously and i may or may not cover it
i don't really know i mean i don't
really care much about the characters
insult in
infinity warps but one of the characters
that was or really a couple characters
that were merged here were wolverine and
emma frost and of course we talked about
that in the last video that with
wolverine and emma frost being sort of
merged together it's wolverine with imma
frost telepathy uh and initially
loki was one of the characters who had
been thrown into this universe
when everything when gamora sort of
changed everything and so loki was like
the only person that truly knew what was
going on but in this instance uh with
loki speaking directly with uh with
wolverine it's just kind of this thing
where like wolverine had scanned his
mind and basically read his mind to see
what was going on not only that one of
the things that jerry dugan introduces
here is something called davondra and
davandra is essentially this
object or this this concept that's
created for the purpose of like
consuming the occupants of soul world
now again this is jerry dugan sort of
making things up we're at least creating
new things because remember soul world
was a very peaceful place con you know
contrary to the way in which a person
would arrive in soul war which is to say
the soul stone would literally siphon
off their soul
until the whole thing was was absorbed
and then their soul resided in soul
world proper in this
divider is kind of like this this being
that was either created by gamora
or has always existed and we'll talk
more about the the role that andrew
plays and you know with regards to the
story here in a little bit but like
devon
just kind of shows up where at least one
of the aspects of davondra shows up and
of course it's basically fought off by
the combined efforts of
of loki and wolverine and emma frost
brought together and so what ends up
happening is that sort of in the middle
of all this
you end up having like like wolverine
you know diamond patchy basically says
look i'll send a
thought to myself or i'll remind myself
of something similar thought to myself
to a version of myself in the future of
this universe which basically merges
with the phoenix force now this is not
new this is not jerry dugan sort of just
grabbing it out of nowhere this is
actually going on
in the uh in the thor comic books the
mighty thor comic books as a backup
feature but nonetheless with this
version appearing out of nowhere it's
just kind of like hey look you know i
can basically fix this for you or at
least you know
separate uh wolverine and emma frost and
then just sort of go from there now this
is jerry duggan kind of playing it fast
and loose with the phoenix the phoenix's
power has always been ambiguous for
those of you guys who are who are new to
marvel the phoenix's powers
are really one of those things where
it's just like whatever a writer wants
the phoenix force to do
is what the phoenix force can do its
power is technically limitless like
that's kind of something that's been
established over the years the other
half of this
is the phoenix force where at least this
future version of wolverine with the
phoenix force also has the power stone
and so that's one of the things that's
kind of hit on here and that's where you
sort of get a little bit of
secret wars and a little bit of uh house
of m brought in here in the sense that
in secret wars you had an infinity
gauntlet that was assembled because
the the secret wars event the battle
world basically dealt with like all
these different universes sort of housed
together and so it was a different
infinity stone from the various
universes that were all brought together
to create a unifying infinity gauntlet
in this instance if a new universe is
created then a new
a new set of infinity stones has to
exist in that universe now remember it
didn't originally work that way when it
came to the infinity stones uh back in
really back in in uh the thanos quest
stories thanos had basically laid out
the origin of the infinity stones like
some being existed before all things and
it was lonely and then you know
basically channel its energy or
the fastest of its energy into the
infinity stones and disperse them across
the universe
and then that goes into the future
stories of marvel where every universe
has its own infinity gauntlet and the
infinity gauntlet will only work in that
one universe this changes that what the
entire basis behind infinity wars does
is it changes it entirely and says well
the reality stone will actually let you
jump from one universe
to the next which technically is not
supposed to happen so again it's jerry
dugan sort of shifting things up but
with the power stone being used this
allows a user to again amplify their own
power
and manipulate the powers of others and
while it is kind of a stretch here
jerry dugan uses this to say that a
person with a power stone can split
those who are merged to split them apart
and so this is kind of boring from house
of amp right like the house of an event
basically established like a new
universe was created nobody remembered
how things were supposed to be except
for wolverine and then wolverine
basically woke up like well really
alongside layla miller woke up emma
frost emma frost started using her
telepathy to wake up other people and
that led to
you know the house of him being uh
changed back to the main marvel universe
in the scholar which took away
all the mutants powers or at least 98 of
the mutant population's powers it really
kind of invokes those things and brings
them in it's just one of those things
where stories kind of build on each
other in that capacity now following
this with the power stone being given to
loki emma frost takes it because she's
kind of like i don't trust you man and
there's no reason for her to
not only that wolverine goes to
basically open the refrigerator and
another aspect of davondra shows up and
this is one of the things that jerry
dugan doesn't really explain
he doesn't really tell us if davondre is
more of like a hive mind concept you
know like we are all devandra all these
different you know spiders
kind of soul-eating entities that exist
out there are all just devandra as kind
of like a hive mind
existing in different aspects or if
there really is one divondra out there
and these are all just like fractions of
itself we're not really given an
explanation to that but wolverine kind
of
faces off against these things and then
basically seems to get eaten and then
you have emma frost who takes the power
stone and she alongside loki basically
leave now at this point we switch over
to gamora now
where everything that goes on that lisa
we've talked about so far takes place in
seoul world where gamora is is an
alternate universe
in this alternate reality this is one
that we talked about before where this
alternate universe version of loki had
basically managed to access or at least
pick up thor's hammer and then is
powered by all the infinity stones the
difference here
seems to be like gamora taking the
hammer of thor which is interesting to
see that she's worthy
but it's kind of fudging the numbers a
bit we know just from like jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers that not
every hammer of thor in every universe
is the same we saw like a different
universe where there was a version of
thor who was unworthy and the hammer was
made for an unworthy thor so we've seen
them like shift around and change around
a little bit but gamora taking the
hammer of thor seems to give her the
upper hand
on this version of loki and in turn she
goes and attacks him and of course
she kills him in the process now in this
alternate reality in the previous video
we'd also talked about how we had phyla
vel and we had uh we had moon dragon and
i want to offer a little more of an
explanation on these characters
so in marvel comics originally you had
the original captain marvel marvel of
the cree empire and he was popular for a
time but when his popularity started
waning marvel killed him off in 1984
with his own self-titled death book
which was written by jim starlin and so
following that there wasn't really a
captain marvel
for a few years i mean you had like
monica rambo who took up the mantle and
then after her you had genus fell and
judas fell was okay
i mean he wasn't really like that great
of a captain marvel it was marvel's
attempt to basically try to find a way
to like replace the original
marvel and for the most part they didn't
really seem to enjoy the character
until you got to file a veil and the way
this played out was that in 2004 as part
of joke assad's grand scheme to rework
marvel comics entirely what they did
is they had the the fourth volume of the
marvel series that starred genus fell he
went nuts
and he was manipulated by cosmic
entities and then like recreated reality
and in this new universe that was
created you essentially ended up having
like the version of
you know alicia i think it's alyssia or
elysium who originally created genus
fell who created another version called
philavelle and so as you know as a
result of this you kind of had two
versions in the same universe and then
when everything was set back to normal
phyla vel came with him and that was
basically marvel's attempt to kind of
back in a new captain marvel with the
intention of killing off eunice val and
having filevel take up the mantle for
herself that was marvel comics way of of
introducing a new version of the
character
going into annihilation the whole idea
of of dan abner sort of consolidating
the entire marvel landscape the entire
marvel cosmic landscape which came with
annihilation so that's why you had like
a lot of those huge cosmic scopes that
were going on with annihilation
annihilation conquest the restoration of
the nova corps then its entire
decimation and so on and so forth that's
why
that story's so singularly important but
fly lavelle was very very very very
you know very popular really she still
is depending on you know at least in
certain circles now of course moondragon
has a far more in-depth history than
phyla vel moondragon is heather douglas
she's the daughter of draxa
her and it was believed that she was
killed when thanos showed up on earth
for the first time to kind of access the
cosmic cube and it killed arthur douglas
who was resurrected as drax for the
purpose of killing thanos heather was
taken to
titan by the father of thanos and then
raised to be someone who could defeat
him she's one of the most powerful
telepathic characters in marvel comics
but she died a long time ago she died in
well not really a long time she died
during the events of annihilation
conquest i'm pretty sure is when she was
killed but the fact remains that that
for her
and phila vel they were a romantic
couple like like they were together they
had a really strong romantic chemistry
which was one of the things you didn't
see that often at marvel at the time and
people really really did enjoy it but
again you know kind of enough expose
about these about these two characters
what jerry dugan does is he actually
plays it pretty smart
because of the fact that the reality
stone is missing from phi level you end
up having like gamora who kind of reads
your mind with the intention of finding
its location and then in turn like
moon dragon sort of engages like this
telepathic battle and the result is that
gamora learns the location of the
reality stone and then
moon dragons more or less overpowered
and then in an effort to try to destroy
gamora filavel jumps into the conflict
and ultimately of course gamora comes
out on top
and so that leads to both moon dragon
and philavel using the power at their
disposal they basically kind of crack a
hole crack a fissure in the
in the the alternate reality and then
enter into soul world now the question
is
why does this matter because this is
kind of a back door way for jerry dugan
to bring these characters back to
basically say okay
so like now they're in seoul world so
when quote unquote everything gets set
back they'll come with it presumably
they'll come with it but following this
it really turns into
uh emma frost and loki just traveling
around and waking people up so of course
you had kamala khan miss marvel who was
merged with kane the conqueror kind of a
time traveling villain the incredible
hulk who's merged with ant-man so it's
like a mini hulk which is kind of cool
he's like talking so much trash
and he's like three inches tall but
again like like you know when they're
split up it's one of these things where
like infinity warps was very very
short-lived now loki's plan
is to to kind of create not really a new
infinity watch but to bring back
individuals who are particularly suited
to wield the infinity stones each one of
them are going to wield an infinity
stone and that's one thing to bear in
mind the infinity stones aren't attuned
right it's not like those individuals
who are really really strong telepaths
are best suited for the mind stone
those individuals who are like magic
wielders are suited for the reality
stone it'd be cool if marvel kind of
lined them up that way but that was
never really the case it was just kind
of like hey man you get an infinity
stone you get to be part of the infinity
watch and it's like hooray you know and
that's
that's really about it but again you
have you know once they actually leave
this sort of pocket dimension
inside soul world and then travel into
soul world proper adam warlock's
basically being like eaten by one of
these giant spiders and scotland
shrinks down jumps inside the spider
goes to a gigantic size and then frees
adam warlock in the process
it's pretty pretty fast paced and so in
response to this emma frost stance is
well we need more people like we need
more people to fight alongside us and so
she basically starts waking up or
really contacting all these people and
infinity warps and then just kind of
brings them all into the in the into the
larger conflict and we don't really know
what the basis behind this is we can
largely assume she's forming an army and
then she's going to split them all and
double their numbers set them back to
the way they were before that kind of a
thing
but again it's very akin to uh to house
of m in that regard wicking characters
up to who they truly are
separating them so on and so forth and
so from there you go to gamora
and flower again you know the guy who
was from asgard and basically like going
into the
well of creation and when they get there
what we end up learning here is that
from gamora's perspective this
devandra entity this devandra being
which it doesn't seem as though she
created will basically go through and
consume all these souls inside of this
dimension and soul world and when it's
hunger satiated it'll basically spin a
new universe and so it's it's
kind of strange here and it doesn't
really seem to make a whole lot of sense
it kind of seems like jerry duke is just
kind of telling a story for the sake of
telling a story
uh but when this new universe is created
gamora will in turn
enter it and then take control of it and
then create it according to her own
whims and wants which really kind of
begs the question
why doesn't she just do that with the
existing universe inside of soul world i
have no idea the story has to be told i
have no real clue here again it may be
one of these things where like duke is
kind of going through and then it'll
like the final issue will be a kind of
tell-all in terms of what all is going
on here but it's very confusing it's
very cloak and dagger it's really kind
of all over the place and this one seems
to be kind of just spinning its wheels
uh but again you know what we end up
having is that with with devandra going
through and just kind of consuming all
these souls again like normal human
beings inside
inside this dimension and soul world
with a lot of the superheroes basically
making it out of life we end up having
like gamora just kind of biting her time
and just sort of waiting for devandra to
finish what she's doing at which point
the entire set of events is being
watched by the watchers now we don't
really know what this means again
there's a lot of unanswered questions in
this story we don't know if the watchers
being here is for the purpose of just
watching things unfold we don't know if
they're actually going to act because
remember when the watchers appear
in marvel comics it's basically like a
huge thing is about to happen there's
gonna be like this huge paradigm shift
but we don't really know what all it
means it really uwatu the watcher's been
dead since the events of original sin
so there's one here who actually looks
exactly like a watch the one with the
fire coming out of his head he looks
exactly like uatu which means this
version may have come back or it's just
a whole different version of his
character we don't really know a lot of
unanswered questions this is this seems
like one of those stories that marvel's
writing for the sake of writing it just
to kind of like set everything back to
rights so it's kind of like hey so what
if infinity gauntlet ended with like a
a reboot more or less like what if we
did what we were supposed to do after
the events of secret wars and actually
reboot the universe we don't know if if
that's the case
it's kind of strange in terms of how all
this is happening but again you know
this is one of those stories where it's
just kind of
informational in the middle ground not a
whole lot really happens and just kind
of setting the stage for things to come
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
we will not tolerate incoherence